music Monday music Monday today's the
day we listen to music because it's
Monday Michael you have Fred aare energy
says MK Ultra I will take that I gladly
take that okay it's music Monday baby I
don't know what the song is I don't know
who picked it we're going to find
[Music]
out at words poetic I'm so pathetic that
I always have found it best instead of
getting them off my chest to let them
rest
unexpressed I hate parading my
serenading as I'll probably miss a bar
but if this ddy is not so pretty at
least it'll tell you how great you
are you're the top stop it you're the
colos you're the
top you're the L
Museum you're a Melody from a symphony
by Strauss you're a SLE Bonnet a
Shakespeare Sonet you're Mickey
Mouse you're the
Nile you're the Tower of
pza you're the
smile
on sweet
little a total wreck a flop but if baby
I'm the bottom you're the
top you're the
top you're mahat
Mandy you're the
top you're Napoleon Brandy you're the
purple light of a summer night in Spain
you're the National Gallery your Garo
cery you're
cop you're
Sublime you're a turkey
dinner you're the
time of the Derby
winner I'm a toy balloon that's faded
soon to pop but if baby I'm the bottom
you're the
[Music]
top you're the
top you're an arrow
collar you're the
top you're a coolage
dollar you're the Nimble tread of the
feet of Fred a stare you're an O'Neal
drama you're whistler's mama you're
chamar
you're a
rose you're infernos
danty you're the
nose on the great
Durant I'm just in the way as the French
would say to tr but if baby I'm the
bottom you're the
top you're the
top you're a waldorf
salad you're the
top you're you're a Berlin
ballad you're the baby grand of a lady
and a gent you're an Old Dutch Master
your Ms Aster your pepid
Dent you're
romance you're the step of Russia you're
the
pants on a Roxy
Usha I'm a lazy L who's just about to
stop but if baby I'm the bottom the
[Music]
top that
is I'm being told the credit there goes
to daily wire editor
Ross that is
astounding it it looks so real there's a
slight the only thing you could tell is
the
slight mouth is like a like a little
blurry a little other if not for that
the the voice sounds almost exactly like
me it's almost perfect in fact the pitch
is better than if I had actually sung
that song and the craziest part is I
love that song I've never I sometimes I
go singing around the office I've never
sung that song around the office I don't
think but I love Cole Porter I love that
song that was and then switching Mona
Lisa to sweet little
Alisa
wow
that greatest music Monday ever
I'm Michael nolles this the Michael nlls
show see you next
time that is
shocking whoa dude what a great song too
you're the
top